change correspondent hannah thomas peter
has been at the university of redding's
atmospheric observatory with scientists
there
the scientists here make the same
measurements take the same observations
down at the same time every day at 10
a.m and have done since 1908 so if
anybody can track the changes
happening to our warming world it's the
scientists here temperature just heading
above 28 degrees but for more on that
i'm now joined by chloe brimacom phd
student who studies heat waves and
specializes in their impacts
particularly chloe let's just start with
the basics shall we what is happening
with this heat wave why is it occurring
so this heat wave is more likely to have
occurred because of climate change this
specific one is because we have high
pressure settled over the uk and we've
had very dry conditions over winter
effectively causing heat to build up a
bit like in your oven
so we've create there's there's an oven
effect happening over the uk right now
yes and this means that we are likely to
break that record-breaking temperature
of 38.7 that we saw in 2019 and maybe
even reach 41 degrees celsius which is
just very bad for all of the impacts
that we're going to see over the next
two days
how is climate change specifically
driving extreme heat we talk all the
time about limiting warming to 1.5
degrees but we're well over 1.5 degrees
of you know heat wave here so what's
happening
so because heat waves are an extreme in
temperature what happens is you see a
rise greater than sort of the mean
temperature because they're the extreme
so you see a rise in intensity also how
often they occur and how prolonged they
are by
2050 in the uk we could see 35 degrees
celsius regularly in the summer and that
equates to about 5 000 to 7 000 people
dying from heat in the uk every year if
we don't adapt and that's with the
current emission cut targets
so that just to clarify that even if we
do what we say we're going to do in
tackling climate change there will be
dramatic and profound impacts in the
coming years yes and that's here in the
uk and also globally which is why we now
need um
urgent climate adaptation and action on
climate change as well as the mitigation
to reduce these impacts so how can we
adapt so a great way to adapt is to
improve
urban greening so that improves um the
temperature in our urban areas but it's
also good for other extremes like
flooding because it captures rainfall
good for wildlife good for capturing air
pollution
and also we need heat pump technology
which is more
carbon efficient than our current air
conditioning and there should be
legislation on this and also legislation
to improve working hours so people don't
have to work in the heat of the day and
these are all things that scientists
have been saying for many years so
hopefully we'll see action on that um
very soon
and finally chloe
lots of meteorologists and scientists
have been saying that they feel actually
very shocked that we've suddenly come to
the moment where there could be 40 41
degrees of heat in this country
how do you feel about it well
unfortunately i said that we'd see 40
degrees celsius in the next 10 years in
the uk last year and i didn't think it
would happen this year and i'm very
alarmed because i know the impacts that
he can have
so it just shows that we definitely need
urgent mitigation so that it doesn't get
any worse thank you very much chloe
brimikum there chloe capturing
uh the complexity of the problem uh
facing governments and policymakers that
there's a huge amount of work to be done
limiting global warming so limiting
carbon emissions but at the same time
the problem is here the problem is now
it is impacting us and so there's also a
lot of work to be done adapting to those
changes that are already here